[MUSIC PLAYING]
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Hey,
good afternoon, everybody.
Thanks for coming to our
talk, for joining us here.
My name is Fernando Sanchez.
I'm a customer engineer with
Google Cloud in New York City.
And here with me is
Sebastian Weigand.
Sebastian, you would like
to introduce yourself?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Howdy.
Yes, so, like
Fernando mentioned,
we're both customer
engineers out of Google NYC.
And we're here to talk
about the wonders of LAMP
and the modernization thereof.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: So our talk
is called "Cloudify LAMP!"
So proverbial show
of hands, who's
running a LAMP-based
site in production?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Hooray!
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Good,
so we know what LAMP is.
That's awesome.
Who's running Kubernetes
in production?
Less people.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: A
little less people.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Difficult one--
who's running LAMP on
Kubernetes in production?
That's all right.
Good.
Well I hope we have something
for all of you today.
Yeah.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
So, like we said,
this talk is about running
LAMP inside the cloud.
So it's all about
modernizing IT.
So if you think about all
of the different challenges
that we've had in
the past in terms
of running something
in production,
depending on where
you are in history,
you have different
solutions to those problems.
So if this is the
modernization talk,
let's figure out how we can
go back in time, kind of talk
about what's going on,
and try to figure out
what we can do
today to make things
a little bit easier to do.
So for the purposes--
there we go.
For the purposes of
this presentation,
my colleague here,
Fernando, is going
to play the role of the
CTO of Vandelay Industries.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Going to
wear my CTO hat for this talk.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: He
actually does have a CTO hat.
So this was custom ordered.
I'm going to be a
devops engineer.
I don't get a hat because
the devops engineers
are very low on the totem pole.
So Vandelay Industries--
anyone heard of them before,
just out of curiosity?
Ah, there's a couple
of people over there
that are laughing at
the joke that we've got.
But, yeah, they specialize
in import, export,
and architecture.
They were very
prominent in the '90s.
And as a result, we're
going to go back in time
and take a look at
that sort of thing.
But thanks to Google
Cloud, nowadays they
have a very modern
super-high performance
IT stack that happens to
be very focused on LAMP.
Like I said before, if this
is all about modernization,
we can't talk about
modern IT stacks
without talking about
where we came from.
So now that Fernando is going
to take on the role of the CTO,
I'm going to take on the
role of the devops guy,
we're going to go back in time.
I wish we had that
fady music and whatnot,
but I didn't want to put
audio in the presentation
to keep things simpler.
So hey it's the late '90s.
Picture this in your head.
We've got a handful of
different websites, right?
This is what the web
looked like back then.
You might recognize the
top left one over there.
It was beta.
We like putting the beta tag
on a lot of different pieces
of software.
And in this particular
era, websites
like these were starting to come
up because businesses started
to realize that having a digital
presence made a lot of sense.
You can't just be a
business that is entirely
in the brick-and-mortar space
without having something online
that you can redirect customers
to or do something like that.
The term e-commerce is starting
to get kind of popular.
There's a couple of
different websites
that you can go
to purchase goods,
or to take a look
at inventories,
or maybe set up things, maybe
schedule things and whatnot.
And, of course, there's
different websites
to go make your own website
for your dog, or family,
or whatnot.
But at this point in
time, the big trend
is everybody's got to
have digital presence.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Of course.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Everyone is thinking about,
"I've got to have
a digital presence.
I've got to have a
digital presence."
And do you know
who noticed that we
had to have a digital presence
here at Vandelay Industries?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: The CTO.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Our wonderful CTO.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: We
need a digital presence.
We need to be in the internet.
Everybody's in the internet.
It looks like this internet
thing is taking off.
So I think Vandelay
should be in the internet.
We need to get on this web
thing and then establish
a digital presence.
So engineering team,
how are you going
to help me get into
this web thing?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
That's a good question.
This is a new kind of situation
to be in, but web things, web
things, web things.
OK, what does this
web thing look like?
Well, if I'm going to
have this web thing,
I'm going to need a
server of some sort.
This giant boxy thing
would work fairly well.
It's very typical of the era.
I'm going to need some sort
of web server software.
So obviously, if you've
got to have a web server,
you've got to have
hardware, you've
got to have software
with everything.
Also, we should probably
create some HTML files,
which means by we I mean me.
I'm going to go code static
HTML files and hope that works.
And of course, we
need an animated GIF
because it's the late
'90s, and anybody
who doesn't have an animated
GIF isn't being hip and cool.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: That is key.
That is key.
We need an animated GIF.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
I will make sure we
have several animated
GIFs, especially talking
about being under
construction and the like.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Let's go on it.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So I had
a little bit of a think,
and this is what the modern
web stack looks like to me.
So we've got a big
Unix box somewhere.
We've got this thing called
Apache, which is brand new.
It's open source though.
I think you'll like it.
And we've got all of
those static files
that I mentioned before.
They're not super complicated,
half a dozen lines of code.
And we can get this
up and running.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: OK, let's go.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
That sound good?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Let's get to it.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: OK, cool.
So I built a server.
I deployed this.
Everything's fantastic.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: OK, so
we're going to-- you're
going build pages for import,
export, and architecture.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Yeah, three
websites, super easy-- import,
export, architecture.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: And
that's all we need, right.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
That's all we need.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Because, the web thing,
we'll see if it takes off.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Yeah, this web thing's
probably just a phase anyway.
Don't worry about it.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Yeah, yeah, we'll see.
I think we'll built something.
So, OK, time goes on.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So
now it's the early 2000s.
The big thing that we've got
going on here is the web.
Who knew that it would
be this successful?
You've got tons
of companies that
are embracing this
new digital platform,
establishing a digital presence,
and having a digital brand.
I mean it's crazy.
The website that we
set up has been getting
a fair amount of traffic.
As it turns out, people are
really interested in import,
export, and architecture.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Who'd figure, right?
On the internet?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
And as a result,
we want to make sure that
we keep this thing up
and running and
doing that thing.
I've been diligently updating
the static HTML files
by hand in a variety
of different editors.
And every time you request
a new page, because now we
have more than one import page
and more than one export page
and more than one
architecture page--
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I love
the architecture pages.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: You love
the architecture pages,
but there's a lot
of stuff that I
have to work on to get
this up and running.
But you know, times
they are a changin'.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Yeah, a lot of stuff
is happening on
the internet now.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Absolutely.
So this is what's
on our minds now.
Now we've got cell phones.
They're becoming a little
bit more ubiquitous.
We have digital content that is
being sold and also downloaded,
potentially illegally.
We also have the internet
becoming this major factor
in the success of businesses.
No longer is it the case
that a business can just
exist without having some
sort of digital presence.
The business has to exist, and
a fair amount of the revenue
actually comes from having
some sort of digital presence
online so that people
can go and buy goods
and services and the like.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: So Vandelay's
web is working great.
It's getting a lot of traffic.
We're doing a lot of
business on the internet.
But obviously times
goes by, and I
feel like you guys are
having some challenges
on the engineering side.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
If I'm honest,
we are actually having
a few challenges.
One of the things that
we're running into
is that single server, as
wonderful as it is to work on,
and I absolutely love the
environment and whatnot,
there are--
it doesn't stay up the way that
I would like it to stay up.
Occasionally it crashes,
and I have to go fix things.
Also, I have to replace the
occasional part that breaks.
On top of that, I've
got to make sure
that the content that you want
delivered is coded and shipped
and then sent out to a
bunch of different people.
So that's-- hey, it's a
little bit challenging.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: And I
think we need more features.
I think that thing of you having
to edit all the HTML files
by hand, that's--
you and you team--
that's not very practical.
So I think we need to change
the content dynamically.
We need a system so that
the website is there,
the structure is there.
But we just add the content
and remove the content,
and you don't have to
edit the HTML files.
And the other thing
is, that box, as nice
as it is, I see that
these Google guys are
like using commodity servers and
they've been very successful.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
I did hear that.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Maybe we should
be using commodity servers.
And I this thing of
virtual servers too.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: --servers.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Apparently you can
create servers inside servers.
And you can copy them
and move them around.
And then you can use
the hardware better.
So I think, I think,
in my CTO vision,
that we need to implement a
content management system.
And it needs to be virtualized.
Engineering team--
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Yes, sir?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: How
you help me with that?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: OK,
content management system,
got to be virtualized.
All right.
Let's figure out how to do that.
So what does a modern
IT stack look like?
What is this CMS thing
that I have to build?
Well it's still a
website, so it's still
going to need a web server.
I'm still going to
need a database.
I'm going to have to come
up with some CMS software.
But now I'm going to have
to hire a couple of people.
Hey, we've been
super successful.
Our founder, Art Vandelay, has
been just absolutely pivotal
in attracting the type of
high-caliber individuals
that we want to have
in our organization.
So as a result, I've got
to hire some ops folk,
because now I have a
bunch of different VMs
that I have to manage, like,
for example, the database VM.
And I have to manage the
web server VM and whatnot.
Also, I'm going
to need dev folk.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Yep.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Because now we're
using an application
that's going
to try to manage all of these
dynamic websites for me.
So I'm going to have to hire
those people, and also a VM.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: What's a VM?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
The virtual machine.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Oh, OK, yeah.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: I'm
going to have to make sure
that we've got something
that can actually manage
that and wrap that up nicely.
So what does this
look like in my head?
Had a bit of a think.
This is what I've come up with.
So--
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: OK,
let's see what you've got.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
So, modern web stack--
well, in 2000s--
so we've got LAMP,
by the way, Linux,
Apache, MySQL, PHP.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: That's
what it stands for!
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: That's
what it stands for.
It's not a genie think.
It's just an acronym.
So we've got Linux instead of
Unix because Unix is on the way
out, and Linux is
the new hotness.
Also it's cheap.
It's free.
And it works just as well.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I love it.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: I
think you'll like that.
I'm saving people money.
Apache is still
actually in the running,
because Apache is
doing tons of stuff.
They're continuing to
implement new features.
They are the de-facto web server
software that you can get.
Also, MySQL, free database--
thought you'd like that as well.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Free as in
free beer, or free as in free
speech?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Both
actually, which is pretty cool.
Although they do have
support services,
so we can plug into them if
we need additional support
and whatnot.
And PHP is this secret
sauce programming language
that kind of wraps everything
together and generates
those dynamic websites for you.
Oh, by the way,
we've got two, count
them, two different
ways of doing that.
We've got Drupal and WordPress.
So we can choose
either one of them.
Those are the applications
that will actually
generate these things and
what we can interact with.
And then over here, this
will do your VM stuff--
KVM or Xen.
I've got to do a
little bit of research
to figure out which one's
better for our needs, but--
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: KVM or Xen--
like here-- wasn't
there something else
that did these things,
like a VMware or something?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Oh, yeah, well there's
this crazy woman, Diane
Greene or whatever.
She's starting this
company, but I hear
that they're kind of expensive.
So I'm going to keep things
nice and free and open source.
So that's what the modern
web stack takes a look like.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: OK, so
you guys are choosing these.
You guys are choosing these.
And is that what other
people are choosing?
Is it very original, or--
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Absolutely.
Do you want to-- actually,
hold on a second.
Let's do some
statistics on here.
I went out, I grabbed
some statistics.
Take a look at this.
This is all of the websites that
were running on the internet.
Look at this big giant chunk.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: One-third of
the internet is running LAMP.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Yeah,
one-third of the internet
is actually on LAMP.
And of the people that are
actually using it, 2/3 of them
have chosen either
WordPress, Joomla, or Drupal,
which means those two things
that I mentioned before, pretty
safe bet if we use those.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
So for CMSs, two out
of three CMSs in the world are
either WordPress or Drupal.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Absolutely.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: It
looks like you guys
bet for the right horse.
OK, I love it.
I love it.
So let's go.
Let's use this.
And then let's move on in time.
We're using these things.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Now
it's the year 2010.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: It's 2010.
It's a cloud.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
On our minds, clouds.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Clouds everywhere.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Clouds, clouds, clouds--
I can't walk down the
street, I can't open my email
without tons of people
trying to recruit me
with this interesting
cloud thing.
I can't go anywhere without
hearing about cloud, cloud,
cloud, cloudy, cloudy, cloud.
So on our minds, it's cloud.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: And then it
looks like this virtualization
thing that we were having was
working, but we are also--
I see you guys are
having some challenges
with the current
architecture, right?
After this is
growing, Art Vandelay
is thrilled with the
progress that we're
making in three pieces,
in import, export,
and architecture.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Yeah, absolutely.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: He's
absolutely thrilled.
Business is going up, but it
looks like, actually, we're
hitting our limits here, right?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: We
are, if I'm honest.
We do have some
engineering challenges.
One of the things that we've
got is, running MySQL locally,
it doesn't scale.
I have to go in
and resize things.
It's not just VMs.
I actually have to buy
additional hardware.
I've got to make sure I
have a backlog of disks
so that I can make sure that
they arrive at the data center
at the right time to make
sure that we can put them
in servers, rack and stack them,
configure them, and get them
deployed and everything.
Also, I've got to--
I really want to scale each
component independently, not
just at the VM side.
So like different web tiers
are at different sizes,
the different VMs and whatnot,
but the underlying hardware
architecture.
So the network needs to
go a little bit different,
because the web frontend
needs to talk to the database
backend.
Gotta make sure that
that pipe is nice and fat
so that everything can work.
Also, I don't like
getting paged.
I've been with the
company for a long time,
but I think if you embrace
the words of our founder,
he talked about not wanting to
do too much at any given time.
And I don't want to
be on call anymore.
Also, deploying and operating
and maintaining these servers,
I actually have a
lot more work to do.
I have to hire a
bunch of people to do
a bunch of different things.
But I've got to
maintain the hardware,
and I've got to maintain
the virtual equivalent
for that hardware, which is
eating up a lot of my time.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
Yeah, yeah, no.
I see.
I want you guys focusing
on what this company does.
We're not a hardware company.
We're a company focused
on import, export,
and architecture.
So I want you guys building
software that does just
that, whatever our
company is doing,
not hardware, not operations.
The other thing
that I'm seeing is
that we're having
challenges every time
we get more and more demand.
And what I want
is for that thing
to just scale up and down.
And I would like just to
pay for what we are using.
I don't know what we're paying
for stuff that we're not using.
So I would like things
to be able to scale.
And I wouldn't like you guys
to be focused on operations.
I wouldn't like to be
focused on infrastructure.
I think we should
be in the cloud.
Cloud, we should be in
the cloud, cloudy, cloud.
Why are we not in the cloud?
We need to be in the cloud.
I love the cloud.
I even like the word cloud--
cloud technical officer.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Ah, yeah,
with the C. I got that.
Yeah, OK, cloud--
[SIGHS] all right, let me
go have a bit of a think.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: OK.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Cloud.
Cloud.
OK, if we're going
to move to the cloud,
I'm going to want the cloud
to provide a bunch of stuff
for me.
OK?
So if I think about what
this cloud thing is,
if I think about
what it provides,
I've got to pair it up
with business needs.
So what I need is,
first of all, I
need to figure how
to use the cloud.
Kind of obvious, but I need
to figure out how to do that.
We developed a lot of in-house
expertise with KVM and Xen.
But they don't quite apply
because I have to learn a GUI,
and there's APIs, and a
bunch of other things.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: The code guys
will do that for you, right?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Not necessarily,
with our specific
infrastructure and the way
that it's configured.
So I'm sure they can put a
button, but it's difficult.
So I heard about this term
called "lift and shift."
It even rhymes.
It's got to be a good term.
As a result, we really should
migrate our applications.
We've got those three big apps.
We've got the import
workload, the export workload,
and the architecture workload.
So we want to get
those up to the Cloud.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: We want to get
them lifted and then put them
in the cloud and shift them.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Yeah,
lift them and then shift them
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: And shift
them to the cloud, OK.
I like it.
Yeah, let's get to it.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Hold
on a second though.
There's this thing
called cloud-native.
I keep hearing about that.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I
hear that too, yeah.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: And it's
stuff that's born in the cloud?
And it's designed
to leverage things.
So I should really figure
out what that's all about.
But in the meantime--
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: It's
just lift and shift
the frame in the there.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Just
lift and shift, right.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: And
then we'll figure it out.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Put that
button, an it should be good.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: That's it.
Let's move it.
And then times go by.
Times go by.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
It's present day.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: We lifted and
shifted our stuff to the cloud.
And it's running in the
cloud, and we're happy.
You're not getting
paged at 3:00 AM now.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Well,
occasionally here and there,
but for the most
part, not too bad.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: So we still
have the VMs in the cloud?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Mm-hmm.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
And we're still
handling the databases in
virtual machines in the cloud?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Yep.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: So, and we're
doing the whole same thing,
just in other
people's computers?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: I
see what you're saying.
Yes, but-- but, we don't have
to worry about the hardware
components and things.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: That's good.
That's good.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: We can just
focus on clicking a button,
getting capacity.
And I don't have to
worry about that guy
that we hired to deal with
all of the hardware-specific
things.
We've retasked him,
and now he's actually
working in our devops group.
We merged the teams.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Nice.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
How do you like that?
Pretty cool, huh?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I'm
still concerned about--
because you mentioned
cloud-native 10 years ago.
And I am not sure--
I keep hearing that.
I keep hearing people are
producing in the cloud,
but like in an elastic
way, in a on-demand way.
So now I'm concerned.
Are we getting the
most out of the cloud?
Are we using the cloud
in the best way possible,
engineering team?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Well to be honest,
probably not necessarily.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: So what
else can we look into?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Let's
go back to what I actually
need the cloud to do.
So what does this cloud
thing actually provide,
and what do I need
it to actually do?
How do I get the most value
out of this investment?
Well, what I need, what we
need at the wonderful Vandelay
Industries is reliability,
scalability, automation,
standardization.
I need the thing to stay
up when I put it up.
I need the thing to scale
so that it doesn't go down
and, thus, does not stay up.
I also need to automate it
because we don't-- we only have
a handful of people, and we've
got a lot of web pages now.
So I want to push a button
and have something work.
Standardization
though-- I absolutely
need standardization.
The reason I need
standardization is we
learned one framework,
one infrastructure thing
and then it changed.
We went to another thing.
We had to redo everything.
I don't want to have
to do that again.
I want to just push a button
and then have it work.
As a matter of
fact, I want no ops.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Do what?
I'm sorry, what?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
No operations.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Ah, OK.
I like that.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: How
amazing would that be?
I mean, imagine a world
where I could push a button
and the computers
would run themselves.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I like it.
So you guys would be
focusing on, instead of
operations and hardware and--
I like it.
We should do that.
So do you think we should
look at that modern IT
stack with today's tools maybe?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
Yeah, all right, so I
had a bit of a think.
And I think I've come up with
some interesting, interesting
components I think you'll like.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
OK, let's look at it.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: This is what
I think a present a modern IT
stack is going to look like.
Let's leverage this
thing called Kubernetes.
Let's take advantage of
better virtual networks,
better virtual storage.
Lets leverage things
like managed security,
hosted monitoring and logging,
and a boatload of automation.
Because here's
the thing, I don't
want to have to power an entire
subsection of infrastructure
just to manage the
rest of infrastructure
that I need to deploy.
I just want it to work for
me, which is pretty darn cool,
especially when you
consider that Kubernetes
does a lot of the work for us.
It's kind of an
interesting concept.
We just have to containerize
some applications
in here and there, and I
think we should be good.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: All
right, so we have an idea.
I think we should work on it.
We should probably get our LAMP
stack and use all these things
and see how it looks.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: We should
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: OK,
so let's work on it.
Let's work on it--
our LAMP solution.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So
now, my colleague Fernando
is going to stop being the CTO
of this wonderful prestigious
Vandelay Industries
and is instead
going to resume his role
as a Google customer
engineer alongside myself.
And we're going to talk about
the actual linked solution
that we came up for,
for any industry that
wants to take advantage of all
of the things we mentioned,
all of the needs that we want,
and get all of the benefits
that we talked about as well.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
OK, so we wanted
to get our LAMP applications.
So that should stay
the same, because we
have a lot of stuff developed
for Vandelay Industries that
has, whether we've been
working in Drupal or WordPress,
we still want to do that.
But we want to put
that in containers.
We want to put
that in containers
so that it's immutable, so that
we don't have to change it.
We don't have to configure it.
We keep it.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Yeah.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: But we don't
want to handle containers.
We don't want to go from
managing VMs to managing
containers.
So as much as we can
use a managed container
service, somebody that handles
the cluster for us, well
that would be great.
The other key piece for
LAMP is the database.
That's where the
information is, right?
That's the core of the
system, the spinal tap.
If we can remove the
operations piece,
if we can get some good
sleep without having
to work in backups,
in keeping it up,
in high availability and things
like that, that would be great.
So let's look at a
managed version of MySQL.
The other thing that
LAMP has is storage.
And storage has two functions.
The first one is where
LAMP keeps state.
That's where your
virtual machine
would save the configuration.
And that's where
it also would save
some static content,
or your images,
or your videos, or anything.
So how about we get a cloud
storage solution and we
plug the solution into
the rest of the cluster?
And the last piece that
we wanted is automation.
How can we put all
this together so
that we can create clusters
with a single click
and have all the configuration
for a [INAUDIBLE]
code in a repo somewhere
so that if somebody wants
to make changes to the
cluster, you shouldn't
have to touch the cluster.
You touch the code,
and then redeploy.
OK?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: But
the most important thing
of all of these things on here,
the thing that makes or breaks
this solution, is Kubernetes.
I mean, like a lot of
the other stuff, sure,
but this is like the
absolute crucial component
that has to work.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I agree.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: I think
it's a good solution as well.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
So why Kubernetes?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
OK, Kubernetes
is kind of interesting.
First of all, it's a standard.
So if we write a
manifest to Kubernetes,
it will work on any Kubernetes
offering that's out there.
It will work on any Kubernetes
environment that somebody has,
provided the environment
works and whatnot.
Also, it maintains our desired
state through failures,
meaning I don't
have to get paged.
Kubernetes will take care
of restarting things.
So that reliability
component is just
taken care of by the automation
that Kubernetes ends up
providing.
Also it provide scalability.
They kind of go hand-in-hand.
So if we're getting a
massive influx of traffic,
we can take advantage of
Kubernetes scaling capabilities
and autoscaling capabilities--
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I like that.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: --I know
Vandelay Industries was
a super-duper interested
in that in the past--
to spin up more infrastructure
and consume it as needed.
Also, it's relatively
easy to program.
I say relatively
because, yeah, it
has a quirky sort of
YAML syntax and whatnot
that you have to
fiddle around with.
But once you get it
done, all of your states,
even really complex
applications,
can actually be mapped out
inside of Kubernetes services.
There are some cons though.
It's hard to manage.
And, in fact, I'll
stand over here
so people can actually see.
It's hard to manage.
It's a big distributed system
with lots of moving parts.
It's difficult to
upgrade because it's
a large distributed system
with many moving parts.
It's very difficult to
scale for the same thing.
It also requires other
infrastructure services
to function, meaning that you
need a VM to put Kubernetes in.
It needs a computer to
actually run the code that
powers the rest of the cluster.
Also it prefers stateless
applications, not applications
that have state that need
to grab a bunch of stuff
on the backend.
But I think I can solve
most of these issues.
Let's take a look at
Google Kubernetes engine,
otherwise known as GKE.
What's really great is we
get all of the same pros.
It's still a standard.
It still maintains
your desired state.
It still provides
scalability and reliability.
You get a bonus
that it's managed
by Google's legendary SRE team.
You can actually go over
there and take a look at them.
But it still prefers
stateless applications.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I understand.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So this
solves most of the issues
that we have in terms of
managing our infrastructure,
except for that stateless part.
Do you have any
ideas about that?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: I do.
The thing with
legacy applications
is they were not
written to be stateless.
They were written to save state
to some sort of file system.
You have comf files, and
you have state files.
So if instead of
running a single server,
we want to run 100, 1,000 of
containers that supposedly
run in the same
application, they
should be sharing the state.
And containers are stateless.
If you reboot a container, the
file system in the container
is gone.
That would mean that if we
put up a Drupal container,
and we configure it, and we
start putting stuff in there,
and we reboot it, it's gone.
So how do we simulate, how
do we get legacy software
and make it believe that
it's running in legacy
infrastructure, while still
we provide the advantages
of modern architectures?
So what we need
to do is basically
get a shared file system and
make all those containers
access that shared
file system and make
it available for all of them
to read at the same time
and for all of them to
write at the same time.
So how do we do
that in Kubernetes?
Well, that's basically
a file system
mount that it's read
many, write many.
Is everyone familiar with that?
So there are a
number of solutions
that allows you to do that.
One of them, for example,
is as simple as NFS.
An NFS could be an NFS server.
But NFS could be
any storage solution
that supports an NFS interface.
I'm sure that you guys have your
favorite storage vendors that
can have a huge system,
provide a super secure NFS
and you can connect
it to a cluster.
Or you can just use the
on-demand NFS server
by Google Cloud File Server.
We provide you with storage
managed by the legendary Google
SRE--
sorry-- team.
So basically, the other
thing that happens
is that state, it's
for static content
and it's for configuration, but
the way that many people are
using LAMP these days,
including Drupal,
is what is called
a headless CMS.
What that means is Vandelay
Industries, at some point,
may not like the way
that Drupal and WordPress
look for the frontend.
They may just want to use Drupal
because it's a great content
management system.
It's a system that they
can use for the users
to create content,
to edit content.
And maybe instead of
offering the UI for Drupal,
the frontend for
Drupal and WordPress,
maybe they want to use something
like the API for Drupal
and WordPress, put an API
gateway in the middle,
and then use their
favorite technology
to write the
frontend, whether it's
React Redux,
whether its Angular,
whether it's anything
they want to use.
So you get the best
of both worlds.
You get your frontend.
Your frontend calls
the API gateway.
The API gateway gets the
content from Drupal and out.
What that means is
that storage system
that has this state
has actually way less
stringent requirements, right?
That's not a key
component from your system
because the static content is
probably hosted somewhere else.
Your React Redux it's probably
hitting the API gateway.
The API gateway is getting
it from somewhere else.
So what we're going to get in
that distributed storage system
is just a basic state,
basic configuration.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND:
And hold on a second.
So you're a Google
customer engineer.
You work in the retail space.
Do you have actual
real-world customers
that want to take advantage
of something like this?
It's not just
Vandelay Industries,
but you actually have
real-world customers
that would be interested
in this kind of thing?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Yeah, we do
import, export, architecture.
We actually have a customer
who has three works too,
that they may be using this.
Unfortunately, they couldn't
make it to the call today.
But this is being live
today, the headless CMS idea.
Drupal is getting a second life
by being used as headless CMS
so that you get the
best of both worlds.
The frontend, you can
load your own frontend,
use an API gateway, and connect
it to Drupal as the CMS.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So what's
all of this look like then?
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: In detail,
what do we have here?
What we have is many containers
running our software.
So software is
the old processes,
the content that we developed
for it along the years.
I have the Apache
and the PHP pieces.
We're running in containers,
and containers running on GKE.
That means that autoscale on
the map, the horizontal pod
autoscaler autoscales the pods.
And then the cluster autoscaler
autoscales the nodes.
If we get a peak in
traffic, the cluster
scales up and down as we want.
The static content is created
with basically a file share.
And that file share is mounted
into Kubernetes with a read
many, write many mount.
And then on the left side,
or the left side for you,
we have basically a
managed MySQL database.
What that means is using
in the cloud SQL service,
we just hit a
button, get a managed
database handled by Google.
We just need to
program the backups.
We just need to basically
let go and that's
handled by somebody else.
And we pay for what we use.
It autoscales.
We just literally pay
for whatever we're using.
And then in the
bottom piece, one
of the things that
we wanted to do
is not having to
basically clip through UIs
and send many commands and take
weeks to deploy this thing.
We wanted to automate
this whole thing.
And in this case, we
used Terraform for that.
Do you want to discuss,
for example, why
we used Terraform for that.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Well, I
mean, as that devops guy,
I like using whatever
is available out there
and whatever the
specific customer might
have familiarity with.
So, for example, you
can bring anything
that you want that
provides infrastructure
as code functionality.
In the industry, Terraform
tends to be pretty darn popular.
So as a result, we decided
to write our solution
using Terraform and a
couple of shell scripts
that actually bootstrap
the entire environment.
Terraform can be a
little bit difficult
to get stood up in
the sense that you
have to configure the provider.
You also have to configure
different backends
and so on and so forth
with different clouds.
However, once we get all
of these things together,
really you could use
pretty much anything that
does infrastructure as code.
Google works a little bit
differently in the sense
that we'd like partnering
with, and we also
like supporting a lot
of different open source
technologies.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Absolutely.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So
we want to make sure
that whatever you're already
using in your industry,
we support and it runs
really well on our platform.
But if you want
guaranteed compatibility,
and you want an SLO
associated with things,
or an SLA associated
with things,
you can use something called
Deployment Manager, which
is our version of
infrastructure as code.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
OK, and that's it.
And what we have also is a demo.
And for the demo, we would
like to ask you for a favor.
If you guys go to
cloudlamp.org--
we decided to do two things.
The first thing is
get all the code
that we did for this
and open source it.
So we basically put it all
in the web for you guys
to use to inspire you to clone
it, to find some, I don't know,
some queries in there and
open up some requests for us.
This has been running
for a few days already.
And the way, this is running,
I wanted to show you,
this is running on--
this has been set up
using the Terraform scripts.
So if you guys go
to our repo here,
it will take you to GitLab.
And you have all the code here.
So you can go into
the Drupal, WordPress,
and inside Drupal
or WordPress, you
will see all the code
that we literally
used to build this site.
And how does the site look?
Well this is Google Platform.
We have a project called,
very aptly, cloudlamp.org.
And we can see here
everything that
has been happening on our
site for the last few weeks.
Actually, we can see everything
that is happening now.
We have an audit
log of everything
that people are doing from
[INAUDIBLE] standpoint
and also that the
automation is doing itself.
So how is this running?
This is running the
Kubernetes cluster.
In this case, the cluster
starts with three nodes.
And we have a node
pool that allows
us to get scale from 3
to 10, depending on load.
So if you guys hit
it at the same time
and launch a denial
of service against us,
probably these things
should be scaling.
Please don't do that.
The demo gods would
get really angry.
But we have some storage
associated with it.
And as you guys can see, we're
creating a volume based on NFS
and attaching that
to the containers.
We can see also the
YAML at some point.
And then on the
workloads, specifically we
are running the workload
that runs the site itself,
the PHP and Apache piece is
a replication controller.
Somebody may be asking, why
did you guys use a deployment.
It turns out that we want
to automate the whole thing
end-to-end.
We used Terraform for that.
And you may know that Terraform
is an open source project that
runs with providers.
So the Kubernetes provider that
was available for Terraform
when we set this up didn't
support deployments yet.
So we decided to use a
replication controller.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Hold
that thought just a second.
What you're looking
at right here
is actually the
Kubernetes dashboard
that's built into GCP.
So if you're
wondering to yourself,
well, Kubernetes is fun to
get running and whatnot,
but then I have to run
that wonderful web UI.
And how do I run that, and
what does it look like?
This is actually built
into the console.
This will show you
not only the services
that you have deployed in
this particular cluster,
but any clusters that this
project has access to,
which is pretty darn cool.
So you can see the memory
that we're currently using,
the CPU, disk, and a bunch
of other different metrics,
and alerts, and
things like that.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Mm-hmm.
What we can also see is
that we have pods here.
We have the different
pods with the containers
that are running our things.
So we have three containers
sharing that state.
And each one of those
pods has two things.
It has the Drupal pod.
And the Drupal pod, we
can actually look into it
and see how the actual
Drupal pod is getting
requests and getting stuff.
It looks like people are
hitting it, which is cool.
Then we have another pod, which
is called Cloud SQL Proxy.
What Cloud SQL Proxy
does is actually
adds a secure proxy between
each one of the containers
and the database.
Everything is encrypted
in the middle.
The database is
completely secured.
So the connection between the
containers and the database
is fully encrypted and proxied
through this container.
So what we do is we use as a
sidecar to the main container.
So the Drupal container
thinks that the database
is a local host, is
in 127.0.0.1:3306.
The proxy is getting that
securely, transporting that
to the Cloud SQL database.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: What's
interesting about that
is Cloud SQL, being a managed
SQL instance and a managed SQL
service for anyone
to take advantage of,
we don't want just sort
of standard authentication
that people can take advantage
of or exploit or whatnot.
If you remember
back in those slides
that we had about
managed security,
this was one of the
features that we want.
So we want better
authentication in order
to be able to establish a
connection to the backend.
And this allows you to do that
without your developers having
to understand any of
that sort of thing.
Like Fernando
mentioned, they just
think that it's local host
running on what, 3306?
And then they're all set.
Deploying this in
a sidecar fashion
ends up improving your
ability to actually leverage
the platform, manage a lot
of the complexity that's
involved with it, but with still
getting the advantages of being
able to not have
things just exposed
to the rest of the
internet and whatnot.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Correct.
So what else do we have on the
services side of the Kubernetes
dashboard?
We can see basically the load
balancing/service discovery
piece of it.
We have basically
two things here.
We certainly have a service for
those that are Kubernetes fans.
This is a node port
service, because that's what
we used to connect the ingress.
And we also created
an ingress, which
instantiates a load balancer,
an HTTPS to TPS load balancer.
In this case, we created a TLS
certificate with Let's Encrypt.
And we uploaded that to the
Google Cloud Load Balancer.
So the Google
Cloud Load Balancer
controlled by that ingress
is doing all the TLS
processing for us, and
it's completely off loaded
from all our containers.
What else do we have here?
Obviously, this
eventually runs on VMs.
In this case, we decided
to initially use--
well these are the three
instances or our Kubernetes
cluster.
You may notice that we
don't see the masters.
That's because the control
plane is handled by Google.
We don't need to care
about the masters.
We don't need to care about
making them bigger or smaller.
Google will do that for us.
They'll make sure that
the masters are up
and they're working.
The other thing that we
have here is an NFS server.
We went with a pooled
managed solution,
because Filestore was
not really as well known
when we wrote this software.
But now you can
use Cloud Filestore
and just create a
managed version of that.
The code that you
will see in the repo
has an NFS server, which
is just a simple VM.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: And we're
working with the open source
community, particularly
people that
are working on Terraform to
make sure that that gets updated
so you can actually describe
your Filestore instance
inside of Terraform and
then get all of this stuff
automated in the future.
What's important to note though
is that backend, whatever
it happens to be, as long as
it's read many, write many,
it doesn't really
matter what it is.
It's modular.
It's kind of plug-and-play.
And Kubernetes doesn't care.
You give it a persistent volume
claim and a persistent volume.
And you just say, make sure
that those bits on those disks
are mounted in those containers.
And then you're all set.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: Yeah but
again, the general philosophy
is I don't want to be
caring about this server.
If somebody does it for me,
keeps it up and running,
scales it up and down
for me, and I just
pay for what I use, it's much
better than me making sure
that that NFS server is
up, that it's being patched
with the latest and
greatest security,
that it won't reboot on
a Saturday at 3:00 AM
or something like that, right?
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: We
can save $13 a month
if we resize it, though.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: That's cool.
We could save some
money to Google.
We have some external
IP addresses.
The other thing that we did is
creating a static IP address
and linking that static IP
address to the load balancer
so that we can
point it to the DNS.
And the other thing
that we did is also
controlling the entire DNS
configuration of the site
from Google Cloud DNS.
So we can configure
it from there.
And we can eventually
agreed subzones.
And at some point, we
can put other sections.
We may create an area for
import, another for export,
and another for
architecture at some point.
The last piece that we
have here is Stackdriver.
And Stackdriver does all
the monitoring for us.
We didn't do a lot of
work on Stackdriver.
I'm sure you guys can
find Stackdriver guys here
with much better
dashboards than ours.
But what I have is a
simple uptime check.
So in my welcome to Cloud LAMP--
actually, this is
an old file now.
Anyway, we have some monitors
and apparently my internet
connection is failing.
But that was pretty much it.
So please, check the site.
Please, check the repo.
And, obviously,
the idea with this
is for us to build this
and learn as we go.
So we will basically upload
in-- we will be basically
uploading the site
with all the things
that we find as we
keep the site up,
hopefully how are we going
to be doing the backups?
How are we going to be creating
policies ourselves to keep it
up and running?
Hopefully at some point, we
will connect into the email
so people can actually create
usernames and passwords
and leave comments
and things like that.
But the other thing
is, the code is
up there if anyone is interested
in how do you use Terraform
to upload this whole thing.
Please feel free to use it and
send questions and answers.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: Can we
switch back over to the slides?
Cool.
So like Fernando had
mentioned, it's on--
there we go.
Its on cloudlamp.org.
If you actually go
there, the first thing
you can take a look at
is like the blog post
that has a bunch of things.
Or you can go to
tinyurl.com/cloudlamp,
which actually gets you right
over to the source repo,
and you can take a look at some
of the stuff that we've got
there.
Just a disclaimer as
far as that goes--
this is a proof of
concept kind of thing,
like I was mentioning earlier.
It is our way of solving this.
FERNANDO SANCHEZ:
It's our staff.
It's our 20% project.
Please don't believe that this
is sponsored by somebody else.
This is Sebastian and myself.
So if something looks like
it's coming from two guys,
it's because it's
coming from two guys.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: It's
coming from two guys,
working part time and also
having a full-time job managing
a bunch of lovely customers.
Also, just as a way
of thinking about it,
take a look at the repo,
and then figure out like,
oh, that's how they did that.
I see why that
component's interesting.
And then you can
take that concept
and implement it in your
own CI/CD workflows.
We don't provide any
sort of CI/CD tools
as far as this repo goes.
We do have some on our platform.
But that's for another talk.
So with that--
FERNANDO SANCHEZ: And that's it.
We'll have software
Q&A. So thanks
so much for coming and
for your attention.
And, yep, open for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]